[Musik]
hey lieben heute habe ich mir überlegt
es ist so schönes wetter und ich will
gar nicht so lange in der küche stehen
möchte aber trotzdem was leckeres essen
was ich mir gleich auf dem balkon können
deshalb gibt es heute apfelkuchen aus 06
zutaten der in zehn minuten backofen
bereit ist und wir beziehen die
küchenmaschine und da sind schon drin da
gewiss auch noch zucker rein und weil
auch es wird noch etwas mehr eingeben
so kam rein und das vanille extrakt und
dann schlagen wir das ganze gleich er
ungefähr acht minuten lang auf höchster
stufe damit richtig schön dick cremig
in der video beschreibung wir sind ein
richtiges greenteam heute so ich stell
dass die auf acht minuten ein wenn ihr
ein handrührgerät nimmt dann brauchte so
ungefähr 10 11 minuten 78 okay das lasse
ich jetzt wie gesagt mixen um in der
zwischenzeit hier die äpfel die werde
ich dann schälen und in kleine häppchen
schneiden
[Musik]
soll die äpfel sind vorbereitet die eier
masse ist richtig schön herr cremig und
jetzt kommen zum einsatz mehl und
backpulver das lieblich einfach dass sie
sich das verhör ich einmal kurz vor ab
und dann sehe ich es in die masse auch
nur ganz kurz darf sich nur ganz kurz
miteinander verbinden und dann kommen
schon die äpfel mit dazu aber nicht alle
ein paar lebe ich mir noch auf die gebe
ich dann nämlich oben drauf
[Musik]
so den teig füllen wir jetzt in eine 24
cm springform die vorab mit backpapier
ausgelegt wurde
und die restlichen äpfel jetzt ganz
einfach an der oberfläche verteilt und
anschließend wird der apfelkuchen im
vorgeheizten backofen gebacken bis sie
goldbraun ist wichtig ist dass sie in
den ofen auf 180 grad ober unterhitze
freiheit und wir sehen uns nach dem
backen wieder vom nach dem backen könnt
ihr den apfelkuchen lauwarmen genießen
oder ihr kurz abkühlen lassen ein
bisschen puderzucker drauf und fertig
und habt ihr jetzt gesehen dass es in
der 24 er springt vom relativ hoch
geworden ist gerne auch eine 26er
springform das ist komplett euch
überlassen
die backzeit variiert er nur minimal um
ein paar minuten machte er immer gerne
stäbchen probe und dann seid ihr immer
safe ansonsten würde ich euch jetzt ganz
viel freude beim nachbacken last gerne
daumen nach oben
darüber würde ich mich sehr freuen
ansonsten abonniert doch kostenlos main
kanal dann seid immer up-to-date und
verpasst nichts
ja ja ich freue mich lieb mich zähle
heute waren so viele da er so schön ist
nicht aber ich freue mich wirklich sehr
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten
rezept also schön eure kiki und der
hauptsache hinter der kamera
[Musik]